ELIZABETH KNOLL: I'm here
to speak as an editor,
as a book editor, for the
editors and about the editors.
This is partly obviously sheer
self-indulgence on my part.
But it's also because an
editor whom you deal with,
if you're thinking
about writing a book--
and I live in the
book world, so that's
what I'm talking about--
an editor you deal with
or an agent whom you deal
with-- and your agent used
to be an editor before she
lost her job-- your editor
or your agent is sort of
emblematic of all those readers
you want to have
whom you don't know.
So when you're writing
the manuscript,
or writing the proposal
for the manuscript,
or writing the letter that
describes the proposal that you
hope that the agent or
the editor will read,
it's going to be a
lot easier to write
if you think of that editor or
agent as an actual human being.
The person is probably
an actual human being.
The person I'm going to call
her she, because lots of us are.
The editor of the
agent is a person
who is very busy, very stressed,
necessarily very pragmatic,
and she says no a lot
more than she says yes.
At least once in
the last month, she
has woken up and worried about
the weakness of the publishing
industry at 3 o'clock
in the morning.
But it's very important to
say that editors as a class,
as a type of person, are
not sour, are not petty,
are not hostile, and not bad
tempered and not cynical.
Because if we were any of those
things we wouldn't last a week.
Your editor-- this future
editor whom you don't know--
is basically an optimistic,
enthusiastic, outgoing,
sympathetic person.
Even the ones who seem most
prickly are secret romantics.
The scariest agent
whom I ever met
has now retired and is
spending her retirement
taking beautiful
photographs of flowers.
Just as nobody in
their right mind
sets out to write
a book to get rich,
nobody goes into
publishing to get rich.
We go into publishing
because we love ideas.
We love new ways of
thinking about things.
We love to be
interested in things.
And we'd love to get
other people interested
in and excited about things.
So as the guy said
in the old movie
Jerry Maguire, help
us to help you.
Meet us halfway.
Help the agent or the editor,
or the entity and then
the editors colleagues,
and then through them
that world of readers
you're going to have,
to understand the
argument you want to make,
or the story we want to tell,
or the idea that you have.
Now, Helen and Steve can't talk.
Helen already has
talked very, very well
about how to express that,
how to avoid the clunky
language, how to avoid the
abstractions how to avoid
the almost autistic self
referential kind of quality
that many disciplines kind
of do tend to fall into.
But what I want to
talk about is thinking
about who's on the other side.
It's not enough to
talk about whatever
it is you have to say in
a clear and lively way.
You have to think
about why it matters.
The question that
we always ask--
and I say this all the time--
is that any proposal or any kind
of book has to answer
the Seder question,
how is this book different
from all other books?
That's an important question.
But an even more important
question is, who cares?
So what?
Why does it matter?
Many things compete as we
all know for people's time
and attention.
If you've got a
TV and a computer
you have access to
an unlimited stream
of entertainment, quasi
entertainment, information,
quasi information.
And it's all basically free.
So what is it that you have
to say to somebody else
that that very busy
person with a computer
is going to want to
plunk down $30 for,
and almost even more
important, commit three hours
of their busy life for.
It sounds daunting.
But since editors are
optimistic and encouraging,
let me offer you a way out.
It's not enough that you
know more about something
than anybody in the world.
You probably do.
And it's not enough that
it's really interesting.
You need to think about
and make it clear why it's
interesting to somebody else.
And what it is in
what you have to say,
the story you want to tell,
the argument you want to make,
that really answers a need
that most people have.
And what most people
are looking for,
and what they will
buy books for,
is something that
helps them make
sense of the world,
something that helps them
not necessarily get rich, get
beautiful-- although that's
nice too-- but something
that helps them find
a thread through the
labyrinth, through all
this blooming and bulging
confusion that we live in.
How did the recession happen
and when will we ever get out
of it?
Why are we in Afghanistan?
Those are questions that are
topical and on the front pages
of the paper.
But there's many other
questions that people
care about quite a lot.
And if you can answer
those questions,
can think about how the problem
that you are preoccupied with,
that you really care
about, can be something
that someone else can care
about, you're already halfway
there to writing a
letter, a book proposal,
a book that someone
will care about.
Now, if it's many
academics, if you're
interested in writing a book for
people outside your discipline,
outside your subdiscipline, if
you're interested in writing
a book for nonacademic
readers, it's
really, really a good idea to
know some nonacademic readers.
And you think I'm joking,
but I'm actually not joking.
You're probably aware that most
of us do not live in America.
Most of us are not
really too typical.
And most of us
have as our friends
people who are probably
kind of like ourselves.
So know some people
who aren't like you.
Talk to them about the
stuff you care about.
See what gives a
glint in their eye.
Your best friend
from high school,
the president of your
high school class,
your college roommate,
your dentist,
your brother-in-law
from Western Nebraska
who runs a company that sells
heavy duty plastic fencing,
and can only fall asleep while
watching a football game on TV,
but who also always, always
has American political history
books on his Kindle.
You have to know these people.
You have to like them.
And you have to respect them.
You have to respect
the things that they
care about and worry about, and
the worldview that they have.
The all important question
is who are you talking to?
Are they real to you?
And what do you
have to give them?
It's not just what
you want to say.
It's what you want to say
that they can want to hear.
A few years ago
after my father died,
my mother gave me the
assignment of going
through his study and all
his papers and organizing
everything.
And among the things
I found in there
were the voluminous
records of a trip
to Europe that
he'd taken when he
was a graduate student in 1948.
I read them, obviously,
with great interest,
partly because post-war Europe
was interesting to read about,
but also as you can
understand, it's
extremely touching for a middle
aged person to meet her father
when he was young
enough to be her son.
There were two kinds
of records there.
They were his diary
and the letters
that he wrote to his
parents along the way.
The diary was very clear.
It was interesting,
full of description,
but it was a little flat.
It was sort of
lugubrious sometimes.
It was clear he was lonely.
The letters to his
parents sparkled.
They conveyed the enthusiasm
of the conversations
he was having with people.
He was trying to
describe things he
was seeing in ways that would
make sense to his parents
back in Nebraska.
The letters had life.
And I thought not only as a
daughter but as an editor, aha,
this is the key.
A book is not a diary.
A book is a letter.
A book is written from
you to somebody else.
And if you can think
about everything
that you write in your book
as your letter to the world,
it's going to have the kind of
life that you wanted to have,
and it's going to make
your editor love you.
[APPLAUSE]